whether you love it hate it or have
never thought about it chances are
someone tried to ban it in 2008 fruity
booze drinks are all but banned in Utah
how about that blunt ban the Maryland
County banned the sale of single cigars
because politicians don't want smokers
to stuff them with pot smoking's already
banned in many bars what about table
dancing profane music and swearing the
Missouri town wants to ban it all how
long till booze is banned in bars San
Francisco couldn't wait to ban smokes
from drugstores in Boston has also
banned them there and on college
campuses speaking of college still go
planning any drinking games alcohol
leeches or keg stands at the University
of Florida administrators have banned
all that stuff children children
children so many bands are proposed for
the children like getting rid of fast
food commercials violent video game ads
the game of tag or soda colorado ban
schools from selling soda even diet soda
and this honor student got busted for
buying a controlled substance AKA
skittles trans-fat fans are spreading
and the bacon dog crackdown continues in
los angeles speaking of dogs there was
an effort to ban a doggie rental service
in beantown how about driving with your
pooch lawmakers from California to
Vermont want that out loud in fact
distracted driving laws have targeted
just about everything eating smoking
reading writing talking on a cell phone
and shaving all drugs why not just ban
crashing after all la tried to ban
homicide for 40 hours too bad murderers
ignored the ban deadly violence in South
LA this weekend three people were killed
in separate incidents across LA County
gay marriage was banned than unbanded
banned again hookah lounges light bulbs
plastic bags styrofoam human cloning
fireplaces they're all on someone's
hitless what else has been nixed by
nanny-state nags well there's tow-in
surfing genetically engineered coffees
smiling for a driver's license opening
fast food restaurants wearing campaign
buttons while voting and advertising
with wind puppets or giant inflatable
gorillas and that's just the beginning
of all the bands so if you still think
you have plenty of freedom there's
always next year
you